[Music]
hello and welcome to the vew from 22
from spectator TV I'm Cindy U the
spectator's assistant editor this
morning the Prime Minister made an
announcement regarding a dog breed this
is what he had to say the American XL
Bully Dog is a danger to our communities
particularly our children it's clear
this is not about a handful of badly
trained dogs it's a pattern of behavior
and it can cannot go on today I have
tasked ministers to bring together
police and experts to firstly Define the
breed of dog behind these attacks with a
view to then outlawing it now the
American Bully Exile has been the source
of a number of fatal dog attacks in
recent months uh and on today's
spectator TV now that the ban has come
through we've invited on Lawrence
Newport who has been the leading
campaigner against this breed uh for
months now Lawrence thank you so much
for joining the V from 22 I know you've
had to take time out of a wedding that
you're at today thank you very much for
having me now this ban is something that
you've been campaigning for for months
now um tell us your reaction now that
it's been put in pretty uh you know
surprisingly I think
today um this ban is way overdue we have
spent months and months campaigning on
this issue it has been something which
has required a small group of people
working tirelessly with no pay just
pushing the facts and the data
repeatedly against a very large headwind
of multiple lobbyists and multiple
groups and really against government
against the Civil Service there was a
lot of um a lot of friction a lot of uh
difficulty and realistically no one
would listen the only thing that would
persuade people and what we focused on
was the genuine facts the genuine
statistics and genuine research that we
were able to do and to show to prove
that these dogs were uniquely dangerous
and the action had to happen immediately
so Lawrence when you say we as
campaigners you know your background is
I think in the law so how did you get
into campaigning for this and what what
makes what drives you into doing
something about
this so several months ago I uh well
really last year I realized that there
was a lot of um very large Pitbull
looking dogs around they were generally
um quite aggressive and quite difficult
and I wanted to see if this was
reflected in any data when I started
looking into the data on fatalities um I
found unfortunately that we had in 2022
experienced the largest spike in deaths
to dogs in well in the history of the UK
since records began these this was
entirely down to the breed of the
American Bully I began to then look into
the history of the breed and otherwise I
wrote a blog post on it about four
months ago that went viral and then I
was contacted by several victims and
other people involved other policy
people and a very small group of us got
together and decided that we would do
something and that we would change this
and so for the last four months we have
been focused solely on stopping the
deaths on stopping and it's not just
people being killed there are other dogs
in one week in July this year there was
one dog a day killed by an American
Bully they are really truly very
aggressive and um there's only a small
group of us working away at this and
unfortunately as you say you've been
campaigning for four months but actually
in that time more people have died uh
more cattle have died at at the draws
let's say of this of this dog um tell us
for for viewers who haven't been
following this because I had to say I
actually hadn't been following until
really uh the last few weeks what is it
about these dogs that makes them so
dangerous so the American Bully is um a
it was sprad from fighting pitbulls in
the late 80s and early 90s Now American
pit Terriers are banned in the UK um the
UK has uh half the per capita deaths to
dogs that the US does and that entire
difference is explained by the the
legalization in the US of the American
ameran pit terer it there commits 60% of
all deaths to dogs in the US we have
banned that dog for the last 30 years
that ban has been highly effective our
deaths have maintained very very low
however the American Bully was uh bred
from fighting American pitball terries
these are dogs that have been locked in
cages to fight the death with another
dog uh some of these fights last three
hours or more the winners are them bred
with each other they were bred from this
and the claim was that they were then
bred with other breeds to make them
larger what we have found through
looking or rather what bully watch has
found and a researcher there named
Gloria has found through significant
research which has just been published
in the telegraph um that there is a huge
volume of these dogs in fact basically
all American bullies in this country are
just highly inbred pites they were
inbred over and over for larger sizes
more exaggerated characteristics so what
could you get um from a dog that's been
fighting stock and inbred repeatedly for
exaggerated characteristics you get a
fighting dog that's incredibly
unpredictable so since 2021 um the
American Bully is responsible for over
70% of all deaths to dogs in this
country and they're responsible
single-handedly for the greatest
increase uh of deatha dogs since records
began in the UK and they're responsible
for nearly 50% of all attacks this is a
dog breed that is quite simply uniquely
dangerous Lawrence you know I'm a dog
lover you know I have a family dog and
very much believe in the importance and
I very much believe in the importance of
training uh and I see bad owners who
don't know what they're doing with their
dogs and even in especially in smaller
dogs actually that leads to pretty
negative and aggressive behavior where
they kind of just brush off because they
can physically control the dog so an
argument you must hear all the time is
why is it the breed why is it not the
owner because so many owners and even
just you know doing a bit of teaching
yourself you can see the really basic
mistakes that make a dog much more
aggressive than it has to be of any
breed so what do you say to that I mean
have you really correlated at bully
watch for example have you really
correlated with the kind of criminal
Behavior or kind of asbo behavior of the
owners themselves compared to the dogs
have you disaggregated those
factors so there are several reasons to
suspect that it is uh not the owners at
all um one is that or rather it it is
the breed which can be um well certain
owners I mean definitely there are
certain owners which for instance uh
mistreat their dogs
and are generally just awful um that is
that is without a doubt but the question
isn't whether or not it's it is simply
the owners it's also whether or not the
breed has anything to do with it for
example there's a lot of dog breeds that
are mistreated which do not act in this
way but we can go B this point by Point
firstly um if it was breed uh sorry if
it was owners what we would expect to
see is a large variety of breeds
responsible for deaths and attacks that
is not what we see we see overwhelmingly
one single breed responsible for deaths
and attacks you don't get nearly over
70% of deaths from one breed without
something likely happening with the
breed itself
two if it was for instance just large
dogs um or just larger breeds that were
mistreated people often say Well they're
large dogs they're not like chihuaha and
that's why they're more likely to kill
you Great Danes are 80 kgrs in size
they're bigger than the American Bully
you cannot find a single case where a
Great Dane has killed anyone thirdly if
it was about owners Greyhounds are
perhaps the most mistreated breed across
the country we know Greyhounds are
rescued all over the place because they
are horrifically treated they are not
socialized they're kept in cages they
are starved they are mistreated they are
hit they are it it's awful greyhound
racing can be absolutely terrible for
Greyhounds and yet Greyhound rescues are
not running Rampage around the streets
killing children these are big muscular
powerful dogs fast dogs that could for
instance kill babies kill children you
can't find them doing that what you can
find them doing is for instance killing
cats killing small rodents which is
exactly what they were bred to do we
know that dog dogs have been bred for
inherent traits that is literally what
dog breeding is so we have retrievers
retrieve pointers Point fighting dogs
are going to fight but it's interesting
isn't it you you you go back to the
science on all of this on on on breeds
but actually a lot of dog breeders and
as you mentioned you know you call them
the lobby uh the these animal charities
for example you know they do have
expertise on these things and they
disagree with you they say that breed
specific regulation doesn't work because
breeds actually aren't a great indicator
on individual Behavior I mean that's
also science isn't it right no so um the
the large rspca report from 2016 um is
completely out of date there are there
are for instance they acknowledge there
there were several studies earlier on
which they say was confounded by various
reasons that you can't say that you know
there's peer-reviewed studies showing
that there's aggression difference on
breed but there are massive studies very
very recently done over the last two or
three years on one of them was on 13,000
dogs one of them on 11,000 dogs one of
them um um was uh well in fact sorry
several have shown on these very large
sample sizes you see a massive
difference in aggression between dogs
bred for fighting and those not bred for
fighting it is in fact exactly what you
would expect if you otherwise we should
expect fighting rings to be stocking
themselves with every kind of dog
because any dog could be shown be
aggressive and and attack and Etc that's
not what you see you see dogs bred for
specific purposes in specific ways that
is exactly the history and exactly what
we see with these dogs and it's exactly
also I want to mention too of course
that even though the uh the
peer-reviewed studies might also show as
they do the very high numbered uh very
high sample size very recent studies
show us to be correct we don't even need
that you can look at the natural
experiment of the United Kingdom you
have a ban on pites the moment that ban
is is has a loophole and a new Pitbull
type enters the country attacks and
deaths Skyrocket in a way they never
have before that unfortunately to our
cost is a natural experiment which shows
better than any any um survey or review
possibly could that these dogs are
inherently and uniquely dangerous so
Lawrence let me tell you why I'm a
little bit skeptical for that argument
it's because I think when you talk about
natural experiments as you talk about
them uh of of a whole society or a whole
country there's just so many fact facors
that go into ownership of dogs right you
know when we talk about Great Danes
versus pitbulls there are certain uh
owners who only want pitbulls because
they look scary because of the kind of
characteristics they have they're not
going to go for Great Dan they're not
not going to go for Golden Retrievers
they're not going to go for the fluffy
cute attractive types you know
traditionally attractive types because
they want this something that looks
scary but how much is that correlated
and this is again I'm asking you how
much is that correlated with the owner's
own behavior and what they want out of
of a dog so again it's it's going back
to the genetics or the or the
training no so so mult so for instance
multiple people who've lost their lives
these dogs were experienced Dog Handlers
um the classic case example of this is
Natasha Johnson she was an experienced
dog walker who was walking her dogs and
her sorry was walking several dogs but
she was killed by her own American Bully
this was a woman who when she was dying
when she was being killed by her own dog
warned other people stay away save
yourself that's the last thing she said
to people this is not a bad owner I I do
not um I mean obviously that's only one
story of several but if you were looking
for a simple case of bad ownership you
should see Great Danes you should see
Greyhounds you should see um owners like
Natasha Johnson should be completely
without any any possibility that her dog
turns on her that is simply not the case
these are dogs if you look historically
as well at their breeding this is not a
surprise if you breed a dog from
fighting stock and then inbreed it
repeatedly for sizes and strength what
would you predict that you would get it
is very strange to think you would get a
dog as equally aggressive as a golden
retriever that doesn't make sense they
have been bred for aggression and
Lawrence you know the government today
has not really exactly said what they're
going to do with existing uh American
Bully exls so what do you think they
should be doing with
those um so a band gives the government
a range of options they can for instance
um I it's it's difficult to construct um
there are various powers in the statute
and it's been amended several times over
the years but uh for example they could
um and what seems to be suggested is
that they will ask all owners to
register their dogs that those dogs will
then have to be neutered um they will
have to potentially be on a muzzle and
Leash in public um and it also gives
police more powers to seize dogs earlier
if they show outward signs of aggression
it would also of course stop people
being able to sell or trade trade those
dogs and to stop them importantly
importing them into the country
anymore you wouldn't say that uh the
current ones need to be
destroyed I don't think that's even I
don't think that's actually a power in
the well so under the original 1991
Powers there was for instance that they
could ask everyone to apply to court and
with the first um with the first pit ban
in 1991 there was about 5,000 dogs um
put up and I think about 3,500 were
deemed not aggressive and so were
neutered and then asked to be put on
muszle and Leash but 1,500 were
outwardly aggressive in the courts or
under uh tests they were shown to be
outwardly aggressive and those dogs were
seized however um I'm not sure on the
various amendments here and how they
interact and I'm not sure exactly what
the government's doing so I don't want
to I don't want to put out what I think
the government might be doing here
because I'm not I'm not sure yeah and
what about this idea of testing dogs for
aggression then um would you advocate
for something like that that you know
instead of an outward ban you would
simply test dogs for
aggression no I mean we know and we can
predict that um an American Bully so for
example their population size is
estimated at under 1% of the UK dog
population and with the amount of deaths
they have caused they had
270 times more deadly than the average
dog population this is not a usual dog
breed it is exactly what you'd expect to
get if you inbreed a dog for size and
strength from fighting stock that is
exactly what you expect we don't think
it's controversial that hurting dogs
have a natural tendency to hurt we don't
think it's controversial that sounds
have a natural tendency to chase
squirrels we don't think it's
controversial that pointing dogs point
we shouldn't find it controversial that
fighting dogs may be much more
aggressive and Loris what about the
argument that people say if you put a
ban in as the government has done today
it will simply drive a lot of this trade
underground you know we're already
talking about people who are engaging in
criminal Behavior one Roundup of uh
bullies recently saw that uh you know
the owners of the house were also down
for money laundering they had been
illegally breeding the puppies I think
from the reporting so you know clearly
they weren't doing legal things anyway
what would a ban really achieve
here I find it's a a strange argument
for for um a couple of reasons one of
the chief ones is that we've had a ban
in place that's been highly effective
for 30 years we have half the debts uh
per capita of the US to dogs it's
explained entirely by the fact that the
US has 60% of their deaths to dogs from
American pitbull terriers um we don't
have that in this country because we've
banned the Pitbull even though we have
for example um a massive increase in
both the human and dog populations dog
deaths have remained essentially static
until very recently when we've imported
a pitbull type for the first time in 30
years we've uh they found a loophole to
do this and essentially now um we see a
skyrocketing attacks and deaths um the
ban was highly effective for a very very
long period of time we know it works
Lawrence Newport thank you so much for
joining spectator
[Music]
TV